[Music]
I'm mark Chen professor Queens
University and my research field is
particle astrophysics so what I'm
interested in is I study the fundamental
properties of the smallest constituents
of matter why do I do this is because
the interactions of particles and their
properties affect the evolution of the
universe and one of the things that we
do in our field is that we study the
cosmos by building giant particle
detectors and we go deep underground and
install our detectors underground in
order to study the universe so a very
unusual thing to do normally when you
think about studying the cosmos you want
to look up but we go deep underground we
go 6,000 an order feet underground in
Sudbury exactly so let me start with
this image which shows the composition
of the universe in a pie chart this is a
remarkable image and actually the
contributions from the CFR cosmology and
gravity program and a lot of the work
from the members in this program gave us
the information that allows us to
understand the composition the the
matter energy density components of the
universe and there's this large chunk
the dark energy that we really don't
know that much about and there's a
fairly large chunk the dark matter that
we have some ideas about and then that's
the component that we are going to try
to go after with our particle detectors
in Sudbury so this image provides very
strong evidence that dark matter is not
the same as the ordinary matter that
make up atoms make up stars make up you
and me I'm going to try to explain the
the evidence for that dark matter is a
different type of particle from this
image and we'll see how it goes
the the image it actually is a
superposition of three different images
there
is the optical image from telescope so
you see galaxies all sorts of galaxies
in the image telescopes like the Hubble
Space Telescope in red we see x-ray
telescope map of the x-ray intensity
what we see here this is called the
bullet cluster and there are two galaxy
clusters that we we can tell from the
observations have passed through each
other and this one in particular is
moving very fast through through this
other galaxies and so this has happened
you know millions and millions of years
ago but what we see today is that in
passing through each other there is gas
that's been heated up from friction and
it's been slowed down from drag and that
hot gas emits x-rays and x-ray
telescopes can show us where that matter
is and in fact we even see what looks
very much like a bow shock in this image
from the x-ray and in blue is a map of
the dark matter this is a mapping that's
done with with lensing with weak lensing
and you heard this morning from Gil
Holder explaining how by looking at the
shapes of galaxies in the background and
the distortion of the light as it passes
through large concentrations of matter
meaning these two clusters of galaxies
how the distortions of those shapes
allow us to determine the location of
the matter in this image and there in
the blue and so what one sees from this
image is that the blue and the red are
very separated right it's as though the
blue stuff passed through each other
without interacting whereas the red
stuff the ordinary gas the hot gas has
experienced interactions that has heated
it up and so that image alone but
there's a whole host of other
observations Astrophysical observations
that have given us the following picture
of what dark matter is and so I'll run
through what we think dark matter is
dark matter we think is what we call
nonbaryonic that means it's not like
ordinary matter it's not made of protons
and neutrons and electrons it's got to
be something else some other type of
particle
and Dark Matter is weakly interacting we
say collision list sometimes but it's
possible that Dark Matter has a weak
interaction and so then that may give us
an opportunity to try to detect dark
matter particles directly Dark Matter is
cold means made up of nonrelativistic
particles our models in cosmology
Telesis and Dark Matter clumps together
due to gravity and it's the presence of
dark matter that actually provides a
seed for the ordinary matter to clump
and form the large-scale structure that
we observe in the universe so physicists
we don't know so that that's what we
know about dark matter so what
physicists don't know is exactly what
kind of particles form the dark matter
that pervades the universe and there's
several leading ideas that dark matter
could be these particles we call wimps
these weakly interacting massive
particles it could be excitation states
of extra space-time dimensions they
could be these particles we call
accion's what we want to do is we want
to try to detect these particles
directly and thereby determine what dark
matter is but there are a lot of ideas
that are out there
so here's a simplified overview of all
the you know all the ideas that are
there so particle theory has has dreamed
up lots of different ideas for dark
matter and and know how they're related
to each other I love this image and and
but the the key thing is that if dark
matter is a weakly interacting particle
then we have a chance to detect it and
so we're going to mount a program to try
to directly detect dark matter particles
in a large particle detector and we have
to do that underground alright so we are
passing through a halo of dark matter we
heard about that this morning from from
other speakers so the earth is moving
around the Sun the Sun is moving through
the galaxy and so the galaxy is passing
through this cloud of dark matter
that is surrounding all of the galaxies
that's that's arter standing and so
we're actually experiencing this wind of
dark matter that that we're passing
through and the dark matter being very
penetrating and and virtually
collisionless is passing right through
us and all the way you know
all the way through the earth and in the
most part the dark matter who doesn't
experience any interaction with the
ordinary matter in contrast though
there's a continuous rain of cosmic rays
particles that are with a flux that are
millions of times more intense than the
flux of the particle from dark matter so
we have to go deep underground in order
to be shielded from the cosmic radiation
that would otherwise blind or detectors
from from seeing these very very rare
interactions and so this is an
illustration an artist's illustration of
these cosmic ray particles generated
from energetic particles that are coming
from the cause both is they strike the
atmosphere they make a rain of these
particles and so we go deep underground
and then the rock and earth that are
that will be above us will provide the
shielding that to screen let these
particles only the most penetrating of
particles will make it to the make it to
our detectors so literally we go deep
underground and we carve our experiment
out of rock and so this is a picture of
the excavation excavations that took
place in the valet creighton mine near
Sudbury Ontario that we we really dug
the space out of rock these giant
caverns underground and then transformed
this into an ultra low background very
clean facility to allow us to install
very sensitive particle detectors to
search for the purpose for dark matter
particles and neutrinos so this
enterprise that's underground in Sudbury
is called snow lab this is a map of the
of the terrain at the 6,800 foot level
in the mine so Noah is in the valley
Creighton - an active mine and and so we
descend underground actually around here
and then we have this to give you the
scale this is about 1.6 kilometers so
it's about a one mile walk underground
from where we get off on the elevator
before we enter the lab and snow lab is
is the descendant of the Sudbury
neutrino Observatory and the Sudbury
neutrino Observatory snow is just this
portion here and the lab is the
expansion with a new space and this is a
map right so you're seeing it tilted
right to give you the perspective of the
map although we're underground it
Nonna's oh this is at a shallower depth
than than this location here so let me
take a quick diversion to tell people
what the Sudbury neutrino Observatory
was it was a giant neutrino detector so
I'll just spend a few minutes talking
about neutrinos where we detected
neutrinos produced from the Sun this is
a sphere you can see a person here for
scale the sphere is 16 meters in
diameter each one of these nodes is a
very sensitive light detectors of 10,000
light detectors surrounding central
volumes of you stick a fisheye lens into
that sphere you see now a 12 meter
diameter acrylic ball that we filled
with heavy water in order to detect
neutrinos neutrinos being a fundamental
particle also very weakly interacting
and so it was this activity that got the
Nobel Prize for that project leader art
McDonald the 2015 Nobel Prize in Physics
art and thus no collaboration that I
worked on we we discovered that
neutrinos they change from one type to
another and that observation is really
important it teaches us that neutrinos
have a finite mass and and the role of
neutrinos play and the evolution of the
universe is being unraveled with this
new information to wrap up my discussion
about neutrinos let me just tell you a
little bit about what's happening with
with the Sno neutrino detector we had
the pleasure of Stephen Hawking's visit
5 years ago and I'm showing this image
to show you what it's like to work
underground we go underground dressed
like miners but when we enter the lab we
shower we clean and we dress in
cleanroom clothes in order to keep the
lab space clean and free from trace
contaminants and this activity you know
installing a very large clean lab deep
underground in a mine you can imagine
what what how all the measures that are
required in order to pull that off and
the neutrino detector this is the
project that I lead we're refurbishing
it we're putting the last polishing
touches on the refurbished neutrino
detector it has turned back on
this year and will soon be reporting new
data and detecting neutrinos but getting
it back then to conclude about dark
matter we have also built in snow lab
the world's largest Dark Matter detector
and so that's that's a remarkable thing
to say that that thing is in Canada this
project this experiments called deep
3600 s because it has currently has is
filled with 3.6 tonnes 3600 kilograms of
liquid argon argon being the noble gas
it's liquefied at a temperature of a
minus 190 degrees Celsius and it serves
as an ideal detector for for looking at
the signals of dark matter this thing is
running and we're doing our search right
now to see if dark matter particles are
interacting under detector that's what
it looks like a sphere which gets cooled
down to liquid argon temperatures each
of these nodes is one of those sensitive
light detectors and the entire thing
enclosed in this steel shell and then
filled and placed in a water tank and so
to conclude I'll bring it back to the
this picture the pie chart composition
of the universe so we have this as one
of the biggest questions in astrophysics
and cosmology is to really understand
the dark universe what what is this
component and what is this component the
dark matter and there's a major program
underway in the world to try to identify
what this dark matter is and one of the
leading programs in the world doing that
it's right here in Canada and this is
our share of the pie right there that's
what one for thanks
[Applause]